University of Oxford being one
nonetheless such acts by the townspeople
prompted the university to suspend its
operation for a couple of years in
protest some of the students and masters
now with no University and also fearing
for their life decided to leave Oxford
for a newly emerging studium Generale
a-- at another city the city being
cambridge and these people being the
backbone for the foundation of the
University of Cambridge so that's how
Cambridge got founded right well not
quite for example not all students and
faculty left to Cambridge from Oxford a
large portion of them went to the much
closer town of reading where they hope
to wade out until the University of
Oxford reopened so that begs the
question of why did some students and
faculty decide to relocate all the way
east to Cambridge well turns out not
even the geniuses that came out of the
University of Cambridge for the past
eight centuries could figure out a
definitive answer to this question
however there are a couple of details
that may shine some light on this for
one Cape which was a well established
town in England gaining its charter in
the early 12th century it also was quite
wealthy due to being the center of the
trade and the Fenland's ever since the
Viking era and had a legal monopoly over
all waterborne traffic this combined
with the fact that around it there were
numerous religious establishments which
are vital for the creation of a medieval
university it seems like Cambridge as a
town was a very good candidate for the
formation of a second English studium
Generale but this still doesn't explain
why the Masters and students from Oxford
traveled so far east when a much closer
town of Northampton was arguably and
even better for a tell ground for the
creation of a university than Cambridge
was maybe we have to look at it from the
point that these people leaving Oxford
didn't want to establish a new
University but if they didn't want to
establish a new University and just wait
until Oxford was reopened why not go to
Redding with all the other students and
faculty or any other much closer town to
Oxford and Cambridge to answer dad we
have to look at the people that actually
came to Cambridge from Oxford
turns out that at least three masters
that taught at Oxford were from
Cambridge the most notable of which was
John Grimm a master of the scholars at
Oxford which is a fancy way of saying
that he was the Chancellor of the
University of Oxford before the
suspension so it might as well have been
that the Masters simply went back home
to wait out the suspension of the
University of Oxford with some students
and other faculty members following them
along is to establish a temporary colony
where masters could continue to teach
and students could continue to learn
then after the five-year suspension of
Oxford ended many of the students and
faculty returned but not all why didn't
everyone return back to Oxford is
another question there isn't a good
answer to it is probably a combination
of several possible factors including
better prices for housing that could be
gotten thanks to the contact of the
several masters that were from Cambridge
the aid given by the local bishop of
Ellie and the fact that the university
had a high future possibility for
endowment as the city had a thriving
merchant community and a Jewish
community that could give out potential
loans plus over the course of the five
years as masters taught in the town the
University of Oxford colony at Cambridge
attracted many new students and faculty
from Eastern England as many of these
people didn't want to travel all the way
to Oxford all these factors resulted in
that the Masters and students which
decided to stay at Cambridge after
Oxford reopened quickly established a
growing center of higher education the
center was then boosted in population by
the establishment of the Franciscan
house in 1225 after that only six years
later the University of Cambridge was
officially founded receiving a Royal
Charter from Henry the third which
allowed the university to officially act
as an independent legal corporation
within the town funnily enough even
though the University of Oxford acted as
an independent entity for almost a
century now it didn't receive its Roe
Charter until 12:48 17 years after
Cambridge so as row charters are
concerned Kim Burgess technically older
than Oxford during the twelve 50s a new
problem started to emerge not just in
Cambridge but also at Oxford this
problem was a tribalistic division of
the students and faculty predicated
geographical differences meaning the
northerners hated the southerners and
vice versa
at Cambridge dis culminated in the 1260
riots where Southerners attacked the
northerners who promptly retaliated
after this the northerners from both
universities left to Northampton where
they started to set up their own
University which by the way is
technically the third ever University
founded in England but these northerners
made a giant mistake they involve
themselves heavily with the second
barons war against Henry the third who
besieged Northampton and one he promptly
dissolved the new university and bent
any new establishment of a university in
Northampton ever again which by the way
had to be officially repealed in 2005 so
the current University of Northampton
could exist with this defeat northern
students returned back to their
respective universities and Cambridge
and Oxford to avoid something like this
ever happening again Cambridge and
Oxford both imposed an oath that they
will not let anyone establish any new
universities in England or let any
masters teach anywhere in England
outside of the two already existing
universities which is by the way the
reason why no new English University was
established until the 19th century when
it came to student and faculty housing
at Cambridge early on most housing was
provided by hostels and also some halls
now yes these were the cheapest
accommodations in the city but they
weren't as bad as you're picturing some
of the largest hostels had their own
halls chapels libraries and even
galleries plus they were to the dismay
of the townspeople what we would now
call rent controlled by the decree of
the king
meaning no price gouging could happen
later on just as with Oxford halls these
Cambridge hostels would either die out
or evolved into today's colleges the
life in these early colleges and hostels
wasn't as peaceful as one may think many
of these institutions were heavily
divided depending on the subject meaning
one hostel may have only had art
students like masters while another had
only law students and masters these
divides resulted in even more tribalism
than already present at the university
and fights amongst different hostels and
colleges was a common occurrence on the
streets of Cambridge for example in 1500
a short account speaks
a two-day battle between a hostel and
the Christ College all while st.
clement's hostel decided to join in
picking a fight quote against all comers
because why not
in another similar instance in 1521 the
scholars of Garrett hostel today part of
Trinity College decided with some other
house tools to organize a raid against
Conville Hall today part of Gondolin
Keys College during their initial attack
they were unable to penetrate into the
hall and so proceeded to start a fire at
the West Gate of the hall hoping to burn
down the gate this plan proved effective
and they stormed the hall where they
looted the premises and drank all the
liquor they could find whatever liquor
they were unable to finish they simply
poured out the college's and hostels
also had a prevalent culture of hazing
amongst the members for example a
punishment for breaking the hostels
rules may have involved something called
sconce Inge where the accused would be
forced to drink from a large vessel
called the sconce pots that could have
been as large as 2.1 liters and filled
to the brim with beer however sometimes
to mess with the people the beer would
be salted or the pod would be filled
with other kinds of unsavory liquids if
the accused finished the pot in one go
he wouldn't have to pay a fine for
breaking the rules however if he didn't
he either paid the fine or was forced to
pay for the entirety of the drink in the
vessel even though sponsoring was
initially used as a punishment later on
it evolved into a more of a drinking
game which is still allegedly practiced
in some university circles today going
into the 14th century there isn't that
much we know about the University other
than that it expanded in scope and many
new colleges were established
up until now outside of the hostels
there was just one College at Cambridge
and that was the Peter house but in the
14th century the number of colleges
expanded drastically going from only one
college in 1320 to eight colleges and
1350 to this growth would however be
stopped just as an Oxford by the Black
Death than its frequent resurgence is
the following decades it devastated
Cambridge killing the entire castle side
of the river and as much as half of the
town's population however that wasn't
only bad news for Cambridge during the
same
tree the emergence of the black death
and the death that came with it created
many socio-economic and political
changes across England most of them
favoring the lower classes obviously the
aristocracy was unhappy with this and
tried everything they could to cur back
these changes in response the peasants
rebelled all over England starting what
is now aptly named the peasants revolt
during this tumultuous time the
Cambridge's town and gown problem
reached its height in 1381 as the rest
of England was rebelling the townspeople
decided it was time to deal with these
annoying and pretentious students and
masters of the so-called University of
Cambridge they gathered in a mob elected
leaders and went on a rampage first they
looted and destroyed a house of a
high-ranking master at the University
and then they set their sights on the
Corpus Christi College they looted the
old court of the college and burned any
books charters and endowment papers they
could find the writers then turned to
assaulting other properties of the
university until they made their way to
the great st. Mary's Church where a
common chest of the university was kept
they took the entire contents of the
chest including papal bulls University
charters and many other documents they
did the same with another University
just kept at the Carmelite friars after
two days of pillaging the university all
the documents and books gotten by the
townspeople were promptly burned in a
ceremonial bonfire set up in the market
square this rioting along with the
entire peasants revolt was eventually
put down but the damage was already done
many books and documents were destroyed
and much of the university damaged in
fact it is mainly due to this 1381 riot
that we don't know much about the early
history of the University of Cambridge
many documents were destroyed and
therefore it is hard to tell what
actually happened at the University
before the 14th century nonetheless the
townspeople were punished by the king
and the university received many new
rights giving it a lot more control over
the town's trade politics and overall
economy to ensure that no riot in the
future can grow as strong as the 1381
did
that is where I will end this video
hope you enjoyed my somewhat
continuation of the Oxford video I
thought it might be interesting to look
into the University of Cambridge history
after finding out how interesting the
Oxford history was nonetheless I would
officially love to thank to the
staggering amount of you that came here
from oversimplified you tripled my
subscriber count in less than a month
thank you so much for subscribing and
giving my channel a try as always
there's more information and
clarifications in the description and
all my scripts with sources are
available for free on my patreon which
by the way you can also use to support
me because YouTube ad revenue are
surprisingly not so great till next time
my name is a miser